[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: Hey, everyone,
welcome to Eyes on Enterprise,
where I'm bringing on Googlers
to talk about the tech,
strategies, and best
practices that are
influencing enterprises today.
My name is Stephanie
Wong, developer advocate,
and today I have Matt Leonard,
Billing and Cost Management
product manager.
We're going to be
talking about how
you can adjust to new billing
concepts with the cloud
and take advantage of some
new cost optimizations.
So Matt, thanks for being here.
MATT LEONARD: Thank you.
STEPHANIE WONG: So first off,
I want to dive right into it
because a lot of
people don't know
that there's a full product
suite with Billing and Cost
Management.
Usually they think it's just
budgets and paying your invoice
at the end of the month.
So can you tell
me more about how
you can help
customers get insight
into their environments?
MATT LEONARD: Sure,
that's a great question.
Google Cloud cost
management supports
a number of features that help
customers manage their costs
and spending in the cloud.
It's not just the
invoice, to your point.
It's tools around reporting
so that you understand
real-time costs, budgets so
that you can monitor and keep
control of your environment,
and detailed billing
exports so that you can enable
those chargeback scenarios
and build your own dashboards
in a different set of tooling
outside of the cloud.
STEPHANIE WONG: So it sounds
like that's pretty different
from on-prem licensing
because with that,
you have a known
bearable for a year--
number of cores,
[? seat ?] spot.
But with the cloud,
it's not as predictable.
You have to think
about queries ran, API
requests, gigabytes of storage.
So how do you kind of explain
this new concept to people?
MATT LEONARD: Yeah, I
mean cloud has really
transformed the way that people
think about infrastructure.
Gone is a traditional
[INAUDIBLE]
process where you're essentially
building out large data centers
that have long life cycles.
And you're moving
to a world where
anyone can spin up a workload.
And that workload potentially
could have runaway costs,
right?
This is the great
fear of CIOs and CEOs
is that somebody is going
to spin up a workload that's
going to cost them
$100,000, and they
were expecting to spend
$1,000 on that workload.
So what we've had to
build in cost management
is tooling that enables
you to organize and monitor
those environments so that
you don't have runaway costs
and that you really spend
what you need to in order
to manage a business.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, for them,
it's a huge change in thinking.
But I know that they also
see the benefit of the cloud
technologies with services
like Serverless that
let their developers
focus on the code and not
the infrastructure.
And then operationally, they
can scale those resources down
to zero.
So how has this
change in thinking
really influenced billing and
cost management for people?
MATT LEONARD: From pure
development standpoint, I mean,
Cloud has opened up all
sorts of new opportunities
to solve new and
interesting problems,
but you can also take
your legacy applications
and move them to the cloud
and really rightsize them.
Whereas before,
you might have had
to deploy an extra large
database for your peak
workload, now you can
scale up dynamically,
as you need to, as
you hit that peak load
and only pay for what
you need in order
to manage your environment.
And what we're
seeing over time is
that as services
are rearchitected,
that they start to take
advantage of cloud native
services like Kubernetes that
allow you to automatically
or dynamically scale your
service to exactly what you
need to consume.
STEPHANIE WONG: So let's
talk about some examples
of that, of ways to
optimize costs in the cloud.
I've heard of things like
rightsizing machines,
preemptible machines,
committed use discounts,
sustained use discounts.
So can you explain
the differences
in when you would
use each of those?
MATT LEONARD: Sure.
Yeah, there's really
two big buckets
of how you would do cost
optimization with Cloud.
One is really about
resource optimization,
and the other one is
pricing optimization.
So in the case of
resource optimization,
you have a few different
options that we
support within Google Cloud
or across your environment.
One is effectively identifying
underutilized resources.
So that can be
through Rightsizing.
So if you have a
four-core machine,
and you really need only one
core at your peak capacity.
You can downsize that
to a one-core machine,
spend less money.
Idle instances or idle resources
that are essentially abandoned,
we'll identify them so that
you can shut them down.
Or even resource
scheduling-- if you
have a cyclical
pattern of usage,
we can help you automate the
lifecycle of that resource.
So that's what we call
resource optimization.
And then the second
big bucket is really
pricing optimization-- how can
I do the same amount of work
but for less money?
And that's when things like
sustained use discounts, which
automatically calculate
the lowest possible cost
and give you a discount for
continually running machines.
Or committed use
discounts-- if you
plan to have a steady state
over a long period of time,
you can make a
commitment which nets
you a large discount in terms
of the day-to-day running
of that machine.
And we have more
models like that
that allow you,
essentially, to buy down
the cost of that machine,
relative to the lifecycle
of it.
STEPHANIE WONG: That's great.
So those are cost optimization.
But how do you actually
organize your business
in the cloud to take
advantage of those things?
MATT LEONARD: So that's
a great point, actually.
About 50% of all the inbound
calls we get for help
is, how do we even get started?
How do I organize my
business on Google Cloud?
You can't do cost
optimization if you're not
already organized.
And so where we've seen
customers struggle in the past
is that they've organically
grown on the cloud
without really thinking about
their business structure.
And so we offer a
variety of mechanisms
to help you segregate your
business into business units.
And so we have what we call
the resource hierarchy,
which is orgs, folders,
projects, and then ultimately
user labels, which are
attached to resources.
You can use any or a
combination of these in order
to organize your costs.
Once you have workloads
organized into discrete units,
at that point, you
can start to think
about optimizing either
as an individual workload
or across all of your
workloads in totality.
STEPHANIE WONG: Does
it make a difference
depending on the structure
of your business, though?
MATT LEONARD:
Absolutely, actually.
We see customers
using and organizing
their business differently
on Google Cloud
depending on what's
most important to them
and their workloads.
We have some customers
who it's really important
that they have autonomous
control of the business units.
And so they might completely
segregate a set of resources
from another set of resources
from a cost standpoint
in order to delegate control
financially for that workload.
We see other customers who
need all of their workloads
to coexist within the same
organizational bucket.
And in those cases, they tend to
use user labels as the strategy
for organizing their costs.
But in those particular
cases, it's really important
that you've thought
about like, what
is the hierarchy of my
labels on those resources?
Because again, your organization
isn't a single layer.
And so, therefore, your
cost organization strategy
should also not
be a single layer.
So think about that first
before you do anything else.
STEPHANIE WONG:
So like an example
could be, not just dev and
test environments, but maybe
organized by project or teams
for HR, finance, et cetera.
MATT LEONARD: Absolutely,
or potentially
organized by line
of business, right?
Take Google, for example--
we're not just Google Cloud.
We consist of YouTube and Ads
and many other businesses.
And so as we started to
organize our business
running on top of
Google Cloud, we
were put in operating divisions.
And then we would potentially
segregate between production
and development
environments within that
or within different
teams, depending
on who's managing the cost.
STEPHANIE WONG: Now that you
know where the costs are coming
from in this case, how do
you actually get visibility
into controlling those costs?
Because I can imagine with
so many teams, at Google too,
you might have mushrooming
costs that are inadvertent,
you spin up a VM and it just
spirals in terms of costs.
How do we control that?
MATT LEONARD: Yeah, it's
a challenging problem.
I would say the first thing that
you want to do is you probably,
and it depends on
your organization,
but delegating control to
the owners of the workloads
is a really good place to start.
And within Google Cloud, within
our cost management tooling,
we have a bunch
of different tools
that allow you to delegate that
control through our reporting
frameworks.
And you can delegate at any
level of your organization.
But we have reporting
that gives you
visibility through time
series visualizations
that you can break down by
environment, by product,
by SKU, essentially
however you've
organized your workloads.
We also have detailed
billing exports
that allow you to get
access to the data
and build your own dashboards
so that you can view the data.
And lastly, we have financial
governance controls.
And I think that's
really important
and probably where
you were going
with this is, how do I build
that financial governance
into my plan for Cloud?
So within that, we have
tooling for budgets,
which allow you to monitor
costs over time per workload
or across your organization.
Or we have quota, which
allows you to essentially set
a limit for how many resources
an individual workload
can consume or what a
division can consume.
And essentially
what that does is
it sets the upper limit or the
upper threshold for resource
consumption.
STEPHANIE WONG: I could
see visibility still
being a big challenge.
With hundreds of teams, you have
per second, per minute billing
costs that pop up.
So how do you identify
root causes and trends?
MATT LEONARD: Identifying
the root cause of cost
can be challenging.
Part of what we offer you in
the cost management tooling
is the ability to
drill into cost.
To starting at the org level,
at the highest level, like where
is my cost coming from, and
am I monitoring for spikes?
Our tooling actually allows
you to drill all the way
down to individual skews by
workload, by environment,
depending on how you've
organized your costs.
And we provide
hourly level data.
Now, it's not per
second because honestly,
trying to consume that amount
of data and react at that level,
it's not really
something a human can do.
And because of that, we offer
these financial governing tools
that actually allow
you to monitor.
So they monitor for conditions.
And so when you set a
budget for an environment,
it's not just looking
at your actual cost.
It's looking at the
forecast of cost as well.
And as huge costs
change over time,
you can get real-time
notifications
that say, hey, Stephanie,
your workload is changing.
You should probably
come take a look,
see if something changed
in your environment
that you want to maybe make
a change in response to.
STEPHANIE WONG: I imagine
all these activities
could be pretty
challenging to keep
track of at enterprise scale.
So for example, if
I had a team where
we were running
[INAUDIBLE] machine,
and then we had a database
team and analytics team running
queries against 8 terabytes of
data, another team with request
to ML APIs, how do you
really optimize for cost
in all those scenarios?
MATT LEONARD: Yeah, it can
be really challenging, right?
Like, if you've got a really
complex discounting mechanism,
like committed use
discount, which
operates on
microsecond increments,
just the sheer thought of
trying to rationalize that data
and think about like,
what kind of a commitment
do I want to make, I'm
signing my organization up,
can be very complex.
That's why we have what
we call recommendations,
where we want to service to
you the correct recommendation
for committed use discount.
So it takes the
guesswork out of it.
We have the tools that
allow you to drill down
to that level of visibility
with accurate start-stop times
broken down into hourly chunks.
But let's make it easy.
Let's give you the
tools that allow
you to make those decisions
for your organization
without having to
have a PhD in billing.
STEPHANIE WONG:
That's pretty funny.
That's the first time
I've heard that, actually.
MATT LEONARD: Yeah, it's
one of those things that--
Cloud Billing's often accused
of being far too complex.
And one of the things
that we've really
been driving at Google
Cloud is how do we
simplify the experience overall
so that users can understand
the discounting mechanisms
that we're using,
and they don't need to have
this deep understanding of how
the mechanics work
under the hood.
STEPHANIE WONG: What about
access controls and policies
and rolling that down
throughout your org hierarchy?
Like, for example, if I had
a database team or analytics
team, how do I prevent them from
spinning up hundreds of nodes
for a Spanner database?
MATT LEONARD: Yeah,
wow, that sounds scary.
So quota is the first way
that you do that, right?
So by setting a quota limit,
you can set the resource limit
for a given team.
How much can they consume?
You also use identity
and access management
in order to ensure
least privilege
within your organization.
And that's something that you
should be actively managing.
And then from a pure
cost standpoint,
we allow access
to workload owners
to view the cost data so they
can manage it themselves.
But we also provide
aggregate views
of that at the
organization level
so that your billing
administrators or your org
admins can view the costs
on an ongoing basis.
STEPHANIE WONG:
It seems like you
have to pull in the right
people in many ways--
the development teams and the
actual billing management teams
as well-- and kind of control
it from various perspectives.
MATT LEONARD: It's
definitely a team effort.
And it helps if you
start with a policy
in mind of how you want
to organize and govern
your business.
And then you can apply that.
You can automate it, right?
You can use Terraform in
order to create policy
in the form of budget,
in the form of quota,
and identity and
access management
so that when your teams go to
do development that they have
the right level of control.
STEPHANIE WONG: I want to talk
a little bit about chargebacks
because I know
this can be pretty
common with large organizations
and lots of teams spinning up
resources.
So do you see it being
common to do chargebacks
or separate invoicing?
MATT LEONARD: So that's going to
really depend on your business
and what you're optimizing for.
We've got very
large customers who
have a single billing
account and single invoice
for their entire business.
They essentially use the
organizational constructs
we talked about earlier
of folders and projects
for each of the
different business units
And they use chargeback
through the reporting
and detailed billing exports
that we provide in order
to create the visibility
and chargeback that they
need for their business.
We have other customers
who basically are
managing via purchase order.
And because of that, they need
separate billing accounts,
which means separate invoices.
And that allows them
the autonomy within each
of those business units to--
instead of using chargeback,
to get individual invoices.
Now, even in those
customers, there's
still an element of
chargeback, right?
That individual invoice might
represent multiple operating
entities within the team, might
be different applications,
it might be different
teams, actually,
within the structure of that.
And the tooling, the
reporting, the exports, they
allow you to drill
down to that fine grain
level within your invoice.
STEPHANIE WONG:
So we have support
for either of those use cases.
MATT LEONARD: Absolutely.
We want to give
you the flexibility
to build your business on
top of Google Cloud the way
that you need it to operate.
STEPHANIE WONG: OK, so
how about contracting?
Because I know this is very
important for a company
that works with a cloud vendor.
How do we help provide
them with complex pricing?
MATT LEONARD: So Google
Cloud provides a variety
of mechanisms for discounting.
I'll split it into what
we call custom contracting
and what we call
self-service discounting.
So things like committed
use discounts and BigQuery
flat-rates, these are things
that customers can negotiate
effectively on their own.
If you come into our
console experiences,
you can actually think
about your environment
and purchase those without the
assistance of an account team.
Then we have what we
call custom contracting.
Within a custom contracting,
we can negotiate discounts
for specific workloads,
specific products.
And you work for an account
team in order to finalize that.
And then those
discounts will flow
through all of your billing
data into all of your views,
so that you can
understand and rationalize
the impact of your contract
relative to the cost of Cloud.
STEPHANIE WONG: So we just
covered a lot, but what can
people do to get value out
of cost optimizations today?
MATT LEONARD: Great question.
I would recommend that you start
by visiting the Google Cloud
cost management page, which
has a repository of all
the content, including white
papers, links to our videos
from Next Talks and Beyond
the Bill video series
that explain basic concepts
for you around cost management.
You can check out
the playlist below.
STEPHANIE WONG: Awesome.
Well, thank you so much
for being on the show.
MATT LEONARD: Thank you.
STEPHANIE WONG: Well,
everyone, if you
have any questions about
billing, cost optimizations,
or any new hacks that
you want to learn,
comment in the section below
and check out the links.
Thanks again and join us next
time for Eyes on Enterprise.
[MUSIC PLAYING]